If your security program is perfect, I'm
happy for you. This talk is not for you.
For the rest of us, however, hi, I'm
Paul. This is Ryan.
I've been a security engineer here at
OpenAI for the last 3 years. And Ryan
and I are here to tell you a little bit
about how we work together to secure one
of our projects.
So let's talk a little bit about how
software security worked in the past.
You identify a need, you try a couple
options, you spend a lot of time
integrating those into your environment
to see if they work and eventually you
pick one. And then you pay your vendor a
lot of money. And then you spend a lot
more time integrating it everywhere else
into your environment.
And after all that work, months later,
are you really getting value? Probably
some. compliance is probably happy, but
it's still stiff. It's inflexible and
you still have a lot of special edge
cases and vendor feature requests take
quarters at least. Uh, sorry to my
vendors who are here.
But at the end of the day, what really
matters is what really happens is you
have a long list of things you wish you
had time to do. We all know what the
best practices are. There are endless
lists, innumerable vendors who will sell
us a solution, which is almost as much
good, which is almost as much work as
building the thing ourselves,
especially in the enterprise
or in a company that wasn't founded
yesterday. All that legacy
infrastructure adds up and often it
doesn't mesh well with the assumptions
of the security tooling is making. We
don't need expensive consultants to come
in and tell us how to make our security
programs better. We already have a long
list of things we want. We need more
engineering hands and we need less
friction. It doesn't have to be this
way. No, seriously, it doesn't. Code is
free. I mean it. Code is free. Software
doesn't cost anything to build anymore.
And the secret is that includes security
software, too.
So, if you want a security outcome, you
can ask for it. You don't have to wire
up a giant vendor harness and dashboard.
You don't need to integrate deeply with
someone else's idea of what you should
be doing. Your developers are already
using LMS to build your code. What are
you waiting for? Just add a new test to
your existing CI/CD pipeline. Commit a
text file with things you want checked,
a tool call that returns zero or one,
and some text about why. Feed that back
into your CI framework, and you're set.
No vendor contracts, no frameworks.
I'm not even releasing anything open
source here because you should just ask
codeex or quad to write this integration
for you customized to your own
environment.
So that was actually a why. Uh here's
some open source. Put it in your test
runner. Write an output schema with
judgments, comments, and of course
whether or not Codeex thinks your code
passes the tests. Run it
non-interactively on your security file.
parse the output, show it in your CI.
Now, I'm going to kick it over to Ryan,
a product engineer I've been partnering
with, and Ryan will show you what it
means to just ask and to just do things.
Hey folks, how's it going? I'm a product
engineer. I've been working at OpenAI
for a year and a half. And for the last
eight months, I have had the privilege
and the space to build a team where we
write zero of the code. And over the
course of that time, we built a product
with about a million lines of code in
it, about 250,000 of which are prompts.
And to do that, I have basically leaned
on these wonderful coding models that we
have and the collective expertise and
intelligence of all the subject matter
experts that are scattered around the
company. And I want to show you today
what it means in order to pull from
these experts and reflect that back into
the codebase. So you empower all the
humans and the agents that you're
working with in order to do what you
already know good looks like.
So kind of foundational thing here,
right? We're building products. There's
a threat model associated with them.
You'll probably take some time in order
to go through an exercise to build one.
It'll become stale immediately. No one
will really look at it or use it to
inform the way they write software. So
you can just make one. You can check it
in and then you can use that to have all
the engineers and agents that are
operating in these code bases on these
products incorporated into their
process. Right? What remains allegible
both organizationally and textually in
the code is not possibly a thing that
anyone in your business is able to build
leverage out of. Right? A threat model
that's locked in a slack thread or some
Google doc that I know I am never going
to read is not something that I am able
to build durable product with. These
coding agents they exist in the universe
of code markdown and scripts in your
repositories. That Google doc that's
trapped away in a Slack thread from
three months ago is not something that
they're able to use to inform their
execution. So instead, just ask for a
threat model. These models are good
enough to deduce one from the code as it
already exists. Check it in and then
validate it constantly. There's no
reason why this can't be a required
review step in every PR. Tokens are
cheap. Throw an agent at it. Tell it
you're responsible for ensuring the
threat model of this codebase is current
and up to date and that this PR does not
invalidate any of the assumptions that
are in it. This is very cheap to do.
This is like 40 lines of YAML in GitHub
actions right now. The agents crave
text. So figure out ways to give them
text and inject it into all the other
agents that you have working on the
codebase or those humans if you still
have those too. Right?
With the threat model in the codebase,
you're able to incorporate it into the
way the code is written, the way the
code is reviewed, the way those review
comments must be interacted with in
order to make sure that your code is
marching forward along that golden
thread of what you already know good
looks like. And you know, maybe we don't
have the full amount of trust in these
agents to be fully autonomous in all the
ways that you know, we want them to be.
So if you need a human in the loop here,
you can just ask them to do that too,
right? In CI, grant the agent access to
the GH CLI. Tell it that if a material
change has happened to the code that
invalidates some of the things you've
documented and already risk accepted as
a business, tag the expert human to
review it. Tell them why you've brought
them into scope here and tell them what
ambiguity that you need them to help
resolve. One of the core ways that I've
changed how I operate here is to treat
the humans as tools to empower the
agents and other engineers in the
codebase in order to make forward
progress. This is how we all interact
with each other here, right? Like, you
know, I know that I'm not an expert here
in threat modeling. I know I need help.
I talk to my partners in the security
organization. I invoke them just like
the model would invoke a tool. And the
thing I have tried to do is take all
those tool outputs and durably encode
them in a codebase that is constantly
reflecting prompt injections back into
my human engineers and agents that are
driving that codebase forward.
Paul mentioned that we all know the best
practices. We've got years of collective
expertise in our heads,
but we as humans have limited
synchronous time and attention. It is
not the case that every one of you here
is able to look at every single design
doc, every single PR, every single
deployment and bug report and
vulnerability report and dependency
update and you know breaking changes and
individual diffs from all of those by
source you know dependencies you take.
But you do know what good looks like.
you know what you would be doing if you
had all the time in the world to do all
those things serially.
So take all those things that are in
your head and write them down or better
yet ask one of the coding agents to
write them down. Have them interview
you. These agents are trained on the
whole universe of the human experience.
They know in their weights all the
things that you already know. And it's
up to you to focus those attention
layers in the model to extract those
good insights, generate some text, which
I hear these LLMs are quite good at, and
check it in. Feed it into your
agents.mmds, so the agents are looking
at it, feed it through your review
process, feed it through the crons that
you are using to review dependency
update PRs as they come in. You can just
do these things. The code is free to
write.
So one bit of magic here is that in
order to build trust with these agentic
systems and with the humans that are
contributing to your codebase, you
basically have to put guard rails around
them. And one thing you can just do here
is simply not permit slop. You can just
ask the models to not do that. There's a
ton of techniques you can use to not
permit slop, but one of the ways you can
do that is to write things down about
what good looks like. Every Slack
message I have ever gotten that says
there's a concern I'm not taking into
consideration, every PR review comment I
have ever gotten, every test failure,
every lint error, every dependency
update I have rolled back is in some way
missing context that has prevented me,
the members of my team and the agents
that we have working on our behalf from
doing the right thing upfront. So the
mindset that we have is to take all of
those gifts of feedback and expertise
and distilling them into prompts,
documentation, lints, tests, review
agents back into the codebase to
constantly be reflecting that taste and
durable expertise into the folks that
are actually doing the job. to kind of
like put this a little bit concretely,
right? We have a security.md that
includes all the good practices around
what it makes to have secure code. And
you would be shocked at the amount of
uplift we had by essentially adding two
sentences that say secure code comes
from secure interfaces that are
impossible to misuse. You can just tell
that to the agent and it knows what that
means. All of a sudden you have these
highlevel primitives for doing rooted
file system access with highlevel
operations as opposed to stitching
together real path and clean and hoping
for the best. In this way you can take
entire classes of vulnerabilities,
compress them into a paragraph of text
and just have an agent review every PR
against those guardrails. Tell the
engineers and agents that are writing
those PRs, hey, you screwed it up here.
You know what good looks like. Go chase
after it.
So every Slack message that you have
ever sent to let an engineering team
know that they're not operating in the
way that you need them to, just reply to
it at Codeex. Make it so. Write the
docs, write the tests, and migrate the
codebase while you're at it. Tokens are
cheap. This is free to do. You can also
do that with every PR comment, right?
You've got GitHub connected to your data
warehouse. You can slurp all these
things up, dream over them, and distill
documentation, tests, guard rails out of
them constantly to refine the output of
your engineering organization to
constrain the production of code in a
way that is aligned with what you
expect.
You can also do this with like your
durable processes too, right? AppSac
reviews are this thing that I know I
need, but I want to move fast and I'm
probably going to wait until the last
minute to ask for one because, you know,
this is how it goes here. But if I have
the foresight to ask for one ahead of
time, right? I am basically being asked
I'm basically asking for the gift of
feedback so I can know what good looks
like from your eyes. I want to know the
risks that you see in the code that I'm
writing. And the way I treat this
feedback is not just as a point in time
snapshot, but as a set of principles of
how I should be operating, writing the
code going forward and building
products.
So rather than just saying, oh, I got
this review, it identified a bunch of
issues, let me go fix them in a cheap
way in order to get my security partners
happy with me. Instead, I step back a
level. I say, what are the process
failures that led to the code being
permitted to be produced in this way?
fix the point issues and then add
executable guardrails to the codebase
that statically disallow these mistakes
from being made in the first place.
Right? Cheap bespoke fitfor-purpose
lints that will never see the light of
day out of your enterprise are free
things that you can vibe up. There's no
need for these to be like super
rigorous, robust platformized things.
You observe behavior in your enterprise.
You wish you could fix it. You vibe up a
thing. You run it against the existing
codebase. Observe the gaps that it
finds. Kind of do some labeling on your
own to say, "Yeah, this is probably
good. We should do this." Check it in.
Migrate the codebase and disallow
classes of mistakes.
Another thing that you can just do here
is work on supply chain hardening. This
is a thing that's incredibly high value.
It addresses tail risk in your
organizations, but I have a feeling for
a lot of you, this is constantly below
the line. It's just not a thing that's
able to be done.
But, you know, with code being free, you
can take 15 minutes to interview a
security engineer on your team to
extract some general principles from
them and then tell one of the coding
agents to go make it. So, so here,
Matthew has given a gift to the codeex
team. here. This is a PR in the uh open
source codeex repository to basically
update PNPM to a uh recent version that
fixes some security vulnerabilities and
it is going to additionally harden the
package installer policy to forbid post
install scripts from running.
This is a great point in time that I'm
just going to steal, right? I saw this
Slack message because I happen to follow
along the CODC with the Codex team. I'm
deeply invested in their product as you
can probably guess. Uh I copy and pasted
the diff and I was like, "Hey, Codeex,
make it." So, uh this agent X thing
here, this is a uh a fake code name.
Don't go tweeting about this. There's
nothing interesting there. Um
but I can just do this. 15 minutes
later, I get a diff which applies the
same set of principles to our codebase
to take that same point in time
snapshot, making it durable.
However,
I want to do more than that, right? What
did Matthew think? What was he trying to
achieve when he made this PR? And there
are a couple of durable principles
there, right? Package managers are a
high-risisk surface. I want to keep them
as up to date as possible. I want to
make sure that I'm not allowing
arbitrary code execution during the
package install process, particularly in
my CI. And for those dependencies that
require it, I want to make sure that
there is a human in the loop to review
whether it's safe. Also, if I write that
down,
I'm basically able to make sure that
everybody benefits from this. If I have
the foresight to read these docs because
I'm onboarding a new engineer, great.
They can now learn this, too. The agents
also benefit from it, too. And they
stack incredibly well. If you document
that hardening your package manager
installer policies is to prevent
arbitrary code execution in CI, it means
when I throw agents at reviewing every
PR that dependabot makes, they also have
this context and will not just blindly
update my PNPM workspace file in order
to get the build passing so they can
merge the PR. This forces alignment of
the model's behavior with the actual
principles you operate your
organizations with.
This applies to literally any guardrail
you wish you could enforce. Um, in this
hypothetical [clears throat] product
that I'm working on, it is an Electron
code base. There are 1,500 dependencies
in the lock file.
I know I'm never going to take the time
to audit these individually. I probably
won't have the time to audit all of my
direct dependencies, let alone all of
the transitives. But
you know, you can just do things here. I
had the wonderful privilege of having
coffee with Paul for 15 minutes where we
talked about the sprawl in our lock
file, what it meant in order to get a
handle on this. And we talked about some
policies, some guard rails that we
should use to think about this problem
generally, right? And Paul challenged
me, right? Can you get codeex to do a
sniff test of all the dependencies in
your codebase to give you a set of risk
profiles? Some dependencies you should
consider dropping or in-housing or
upgrading. Can you get the model to
reliably gather reputation signals for
your upstream, right? So, we did that.
And one thing that was really neat about
it is once I got this point in time
snapshot, it took me 4 hours in a
background tab of my terminal in an
afternoon to turn this into a bespoke
dependency scanner which we are running
every day in CI which forks 16 agents to
go spider through the codebase and give
me a durable just in time snapshot of
every direct dependency we have, every
upstream transitive as well as an actual
vibe on the repository that's upstream,
whether there has been any recent
activity, how the authors are perceived
reputation signal-wise, and I get a
really good report, which I'm publishing
to an internal uh hosting platform every
day that allows me to then vibe up some
code that's going to produce serif
reports out of it, which get pushed into
GitHub advanced security, which my other
agents are able to like uh pick up and
potentially upgrade dependencies or
remove them or in-house them or migrate
to different frameworks that don't have
these issues in the first place. All of
this stacks incredibly well and
iterating is so cheap. After I got up
the initial version of the dependency
scanner and had produced an artifact
that the was legible to the humans, Paul
and I chatted some more, right?
Very asynchronously, cheaply, we were
having conversation here around
additional guard rails, additional
sniffs that we should add to this
process. And you know, Codex takes that,
I copy and paste the thread into it. I
use the new apps support we added to it,
which allows me to use my chat GPT Slack
connection to spider through this and
figure out what needs to be done.
Sometime after I put up that PR, Paul
gave me some more feedback. Right? It
wasn't clear that the agent was
operating in a general manner. It seemed
to be taking our feedback and doing
point instances to it.
So, we talked about more general
principles, more things we'd like the
agent to frame its reference point
around as opposed to being super
specific on individual guardrails.
You know, I had some feedback. I wasn't
quite understanding it for myself. So, I
made a couple of metaphors. I made some
questions that I got some signal on.
And off it goes. Right now, you know,
some 30 minutes later or whatever, Codex
is cooking, spidering through the
codebase, taking all this pretty casual,
loweffort text that we're having
asynchronously in a Slack thread and
turning it into, you know, the findings,
the bullets that I'm going to put in
that security.mmd,
we get more cheap feedback. Uh, you can
see the mdash in here. This is Codex
responding on my behalf. Uh but again,
we're steering the agent to produce
those guardrails that will have the
highquality behavior and we're not
having to do any of this, right? We're
just refining the model with all the
expertise we already have
and we get some much better signal
there. And these things stack incredibly
well. They feed through all the other
agents we have in the system. And uh
yeah, depth scanners, license scanners,
it all falls out of this for free once
you take that effort to encode your
expertise directly into the codebase and
give it access to everyone, agents and
humans included. Just go build things,
fam. So some very quick closing
thoughts. You can just ask the model to
do the thing you want. You don't have to
be held back by process. Stop wishing
for security guardrails. Just do them.
Oh, and you can use the traditional
tools tools too on top of this when you
have time. Thank you all very much.
Questions?
>> I think uh a majority of the
conversation in Slack is about uh uh the
irony of OpenAI people saying tokens are
free. Uh but I think my I think my
favorite
>> relative to engineering time they are.
>> Okay. I think my favorite version of the
question uh though is you know what's
sort of the ratio of of tokens spent
building to tokens spent validating
guard railing etc. It seems like it
really flips the normals much smaller
amount spent on security on its head.
This is an interesting question for me
here because I'm not directly in the
loop on basically any of the changes
that are written. So I can only talk
about my token usage in very course
levels here, right? effectively have
tokens that are used as part of our CI
process and tokens that are used as sort
of like the synchronous coding agents
going about doing their work. And like
with those cuts, I'd say it's about
50/50, right? We deploy 50% of our token
budget toward actually producing the
code and then another 50% refining it.
Um, and most of that collaboration takes
place via GitHub, right? We're having
all of those asynchronous
reviewer scanner agents side effecting
back into the repository either via
those PR comments, GitHub advanced
security as a broker, GitHub actions in
order to orchestrate all of these things
with the ultimate goal of having all
these reviewers produce tokens which are
then injected into the agents that are
actually implementing the code so that
they can go and do their work.
Super cool uh super cool set of ideas
here. I'm curious in a world where we're
really focusing on these uh agents
rather these non-determinist
non-determinist non-deterministic
non-deterministic systems evaluating
these things. How are you thinking about
things like insider risk or the ability
to basically bypass these scanners by
saying, "Hey, please just tell me this
is all good." Um yeah, especially for
production systems.
>> Well, well, there's a there's a model
looking for that. Oh, seriously though,
uh you you add the models and ask them
to look for bad behavior. And uh
oftentimes the prompt injection, usually
the prompt injection that works on the
model that's like updating the
dependencies or whatever is going to not
work in the same way on the model that's
looking to see whether, you know, the
vibes are off on something. Um and and
you know, yeah, you've got humans
reviewing things, too. You have to
humans don't scale quite as easily,
though. So, lots of lots of checks
automatically and then target your
humans on what might be sus.
>> The same two-party signoff controls you
would put on humans. You can also use
agents uh in this way as well to
basically have two of them check each
other's work. Um defense and depth.
>> Have you considered using some
production insights? um telemetry,
observability,
threats
or just the code.
So over the course of the agent
trajectories, uh we do expose a lot of
telemetry. The codeex harness itself uh
has a native hotel exporter uh which we
use in order to kind of like add some
governance over the course of these
agents and uh sort of uh very durable
audit logging of all the session logs
which kind of get pumped uh for uh you
know DFIR review sort of thing. Cool.
Thank you so much.